If you remember how to count the digits of a number you'll remember that you'll
need a temp so that we can count down the digits without messing up number. Now
we're going to repeatedly divide temp by ten to count the, now we're going to
repeatedly divide temp by ten to iterate through the digits from the last to
the first. So the way that we'll iterate through each digit in the number is to
first use mod to get the last digit and then divide by 10 so that we discard
the last digit. Then when we use mod 10 again, we'll get the next last digit.
So the first digit will be temp mod 10 and then we divide temp by 10 to discard
the last digit. Now in here we want to be counting all of the digits that match
digit to match. So we'll need a counter. That starts out at 0. And then every
time we find a digit that matches digit to match the increment, the counter, I
think I might have some type errors in here, because I'm mixing int and long.
But let's see. Alright. I know that when I mod something by 10, the biggest
number I'll get is nine. So I know that's it's safe to actually cast this after
I take the mod and I will actually need to return the count. I wrote tester
here to make sure my program works right. In this number I expect there to be
four 9's, one 3's, and no fives. Since I fix all my syntax errors, I'll run my
number tester, it looks good.